Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. Today we're going to be talking about one of the big isms. You know, you'll often meet a socialist, an anarchist, even a communist. It's very rare that you'll meet somebody who will willingly describe themselves as a fascist. So what is fascism? What are its roots? Are all fascists Nazis? Are any fascists Democrats? And
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告广播、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。您好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。今天我们要探讨的是那些带有“主义”（ism）的大思想之一。你知道的，你经常会遇到社会主义者、无政府主义者，甚至是共产主义者。但你很少会遇到有人会心甘情愿地形容自己为法西斯主义者。那么，什么是法西斯主义？它的根源是什么？所有的法西斯主义者都是纳粹吗？有法西斯主义者是民主党人吗？以及
are all fascists uniquely evil? Welcome to The Rest Is History, the podcast that roams down the dark alleys of political history and shines a torch on the sometimes disturbing ideas that you find in the corners. I'm Dominic Sandbrook and with me is Chief Liberal Elite Investigator Tom Holland. Hello, Tom, how are you very well thank you dominic thanks so tom we had the most colossal postbag on fascism as you might expect it's a subject that basically never fails to sell books or let's hope podcasts so um what have we found share some of your some of your um some of your questions that you've dug up well looking through them um i think that large numbers of them are saying, actually, what is fascism? And there's a question from Kelvin that I think zooms in very well on perhaps what's the core issue. He asks, is there an actual historical definition of fascism? Or is it more of a I know it when I see it type of scenario? And then he adds, for instance, could retrospectively the Spartans of ancient Greece count? So I think that at the heart is, is fascism something that can be
所有的法西斯主义者都是独一无二的恶魔吗？欢迎收听《历史的余烬》，这是一档漫步于政治历史的黑暗小巷、并用手电筒照亮藏在角落里有时令人不安的思想的播客。我是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook），和我在一起的是首席自由派精英调查员汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）。你好，汤姆，你好吗？我很好，谢谢你，多米尼克，谢谢。所以，汤姆，正如你所料，我们收到了关于法西斯主义的大量来信。这基本上是一个从未能卖出书的题材，或者我们希望也能卖出播客。所以，嗯，我们发现了什么？分享一些你挖掘出的问题吧。嗯，翻阅这些信件时，我发现有相当一部分人实际上在问：“法西斯主义到底是什么？”凯尔文（Kelvin）提出了一个问题，我认为它很好地切中了核心问题。他问：法西斯主义有实际的历史定义吗？还是更类似于“我一眼就能认出来”的那种情况？然后他补充说，例如，古代希腊的斯巴达人可以追溯性地算作法西斯吗？所以我认为，核心问题在于，法西斯主义是否可以
abstracted from history? Is it something that can describe maybe an attitude towards authoritarianism or racism or whatever, that is a constant throughout history? Or is it something that is rooted in very specific cultural, political, economic circumstances? And personally, I would go for the latter. I don't know how you feel. You're the modern historian. What's your take on that? I absolutely would go for the latter. I would say it is, people use fascist now to mean evil, don't they? Which I think is sort of wrong. I mean, I'm not saying fascists weren't evil, but it's not, to use it as a moral shorthand, I think is sort of wrong. I mean, I'm not saying fascists weren't evil, but it's not, to use it as a moral shorthand, I think is wrong. I think fascism was rooted in a very specific time and place in the decades after the First World War. I think the First World War was absolutely
从历史中抽象出来？它是否可以用来描述某种对极权主义、种族主义等贯穿历史始终的态度的特征？还是说它植根于非常具体的文化、政治和经济环境？就我个人而言，我会选择后者。我不知道你的感觉如何。你是现代历史学家。你对此有何看法？我绝对会选择后者。我会说，现在人们用“法西斯”来指代邪恶，不是吗？我认为这在某种程度上是错误的。我的意思是，我并不是说法西斯分子不邪恶，但将其作为一种道德上的简写，我认为是错误的。我的意思是，我并不是说法西斯分子不邪恶，但将其作为一种道德上的简写，我认为是错误的。我认为法西斯主义植根于第一次世界大战后几十年的一个非常特定的时间和地点。我认为第一次世界大战对于
central to fascism. And historians, to answer Kelvin's question, historians have spent enormous amounts of time and ink debating what fascism is. And they come back to, by and large, people like Robert Paxton and Roger Griffin, these sort of landmark historians of fascism, they come back to the same things. So it's rooted in a nation that has a sense of victimhood and humiliation, and often through war. And it strives for a kind of national rebirth. It rejects democracy. It defines itself against communism. It argues that there's room for a kind of revolutionary movement that will remake the nation and will restore its lost kind of virility
法西斯主义至关重要。历史学家们——为了回答凯尔文的问题——花了大把的时间和笔墨来争论法西斯主义到底是什么。总的来说，罗伯特·帕克斯顿（Robert Paxton）和罗杰·格里芬（Roger Griffin）这样法西斯主义的标志性历史学家，他们的观点最终都会归结到相同的事情上。它植根于一个具有受害者情结和羞辱感的国家，而这种羞辱感往往是通过战争造成的。它渴望一种国家的精神重生。它排斥民主。它将自己定义为共产主义的对立面。它认为，有必要进行一场能够重塑国家、恢复其失去的元气
and its lost pride and create new men, in fact, will create a new kind of human being through speed and spectacle and technology and violence and violence is always at the at the core of it and you can see I think now maybe you'll disagree with me about this Tom but I think although you can see elements of all those things in earlier movements and some of them are kind of timeless the formula is very specific and is rooted in that experience of of the first World War and the sort of sense of humiliation afterwards. Yeah, I mean, my take on it is perhaps a kind of slightly strange one,
以及失去的自豪感，并创造新人的革命运动——事实上，它将通过速度、奇观、技术和暴力创造一种新型人类，而暴力始终是其核心。你现在可以看到——也许你会不同意我的看法，汤姆——但我认为，尽管你可以在早期的运动中看到所有这些事物的元素，其中有些甚至是永恒的，但这个公式非常具体，并植根于第一次世界大战的经历以及战后那种屈辱感。是的，我的看法可能有点奇怪，
because I've never studied fascism. I never did it at school, never did it at university. And the only time I've written about it was in the context of writing about Christianity. And it seems to me that fascism is the most profoundly revolutionary movement that Europe has witnessed, because it represents an overturning, not just of institutional Christian norms, as the French Revolution and the Russian Revolution did, but an attack on some of the core fundamental values of Christianity that liberal post-Christianity has inherited. And I would fix on two in particular. At the heart of Christianity, as evinced by the image of Christ on the cross, is the idea that there is a kind of a virtue in victimhood, that those who are the first shall be last, the last shall be first. The Nazis obviously do not agree with that, neither do
因为我从未研究过法西斯主义。我从未在学校或大学里学过它，我唯一一次写到它是在撰写关于基督教的背景下。在我看来，法西斯主义是欧洲见证过的最深刻的革命运动，因为它代表着一种颠覆——正如法国大革命和俄国大革命所做的那样，不仅是对制度化基督教规范的颠覆，更是对自由主义后基督教所继承的基督教一些核心基本价值观的攻击。我会特别指出其中两个。在基督教的核心，正如十字架上的基督形象所证明的那样，存在着这样一种观念：受害者身份具有某种美德，即“最后将成为最先的，最先将成为最后的”。纳粹显然不同意这一点，
the fascists under Mussolini. The other core Christian idea is that there is a universal human dignity, that all human beings are created equally in the image of God. And that, as St. Paul puts it, there is no Jew or Greek. Now, obviously, the Nazis in particular are very, very keen on the idea that Jews and Greeks are fundamentally separate and distinct. And I think that fundamentally, we've already talked about Nazis and fascists being evil. That, of course, is essentially a kind of Christian categorisation. And I think that the reason that we do that so readily is precisely the fact that the fascists and the Nazis in particular assaulted the core moral values of what the core moral values that we still have today, to the degree that I think that to an extent, we no longer, one of the reasons that institutional Christianity has declined
墨索里尼之下的法西斯分子也不同意这一点。另一个核心的基督教理念是，人人都具有普遍的人类尊严，所有人都是按上帝的形象平等创造的。正如圣保罗所说，没有犹太人或希腊人之分。现在，很明显，纳粹尤其非常热衷于犹太人和希腊人本质上是截然分开且不同的观点。我认为，根本上来说，我们刚才已经讨论过纳粹和法西斯分子是邪恶的。这当然本质上是一种基督教的分类。我认为我们之所以这么痛快地得出这个结论，恰恰是因为法西斯分子，尤其是纳粹分子，冲击了我们至今仍拥有的核心道德价值。以至于我认为某种程度上，我们不再……自第二次世界大战以来，制度化基督教之所以急剧衰落的原因之一，
so profoundly since the Second World War is that in a sense, the Nazis do the job for us. Hitler, in a sense, is Satan. The Nazis are the demons. Auschwitz is hell. And so if we want to know, in previous generations, if we wanted to know what the right thing is, what is good, what is morally good, we would say, what would Jesus do
是因为在某种意义上，纳粹替我们做了这项工作。从某种意义上说，希特勒就是撒旦。纳粹就是恶魔。奥斯威辛就是地狱。所以，如果我们想知道——在前几代人中，如果我们想知道什么是正确的做法，什么是好的，什么是道德上的好，我们会说：耶稣会怎么做，然后照着做？现在，我们倾向于问：希特勒会怎么做，然后做相反的事情。所以它已经成为了一种道德标尺，不是吗？但我要把你从基督教稍微拉向罗马人，这是你的另一个主要研究领域之一。所以，第一批法西斯分子——我的意思是，有很多关于法西斯主义起源的问题——但第一批真正成功的法西斯政党显然在意大利。正是在意大利和墨索里尼统治下，你才有了“法西斯主义”这个词的发明以及法西斯标志。他们立刻回顾了罗马人。那是什么？我的意思是，法西斯束棒（fasces），我假设这是正确的发音。这到底是是怎么回事？那些东西是什么？所以法西斯束棒的概念是，它们是棍棒，桦木束棒。在罗马共和国，它们是地方官
and do it? Now we tend to ask what would Hitler do and do the opposite. So it's become a sort of moral yardstick, hasn't it? But let me drag you for a second away from Christianity and towards the Romans, which is one of your other big fields. So the first fascists, I mean, there's lots of questions about the origins of fascism, but the first really successful fascist party was obviously in Italy. And it was in Italy and Mussolini that you had the invention of the term fascism and the fascist iconography. And they were looking back straight away to the Romans. And what is that? I mean, the fasces, I assume that's the right pronunciation. What's all that about? What are those things? So the idea of the fasces is that they're rods, birching rods. And in the Roman Republic, they are emblems of a magistrate's
有权鞭笞反对他的人的象征。它们由被称为利克托（lictors）的官员扛在肩上，跟随地方官四处游行。法西斯束棒的象征意义在于，你可以折断一根棍棒，但如果把它们捆在一起，你就折不断。因此，这对墨索里尼的吸引力是显而易见的：如果你能将整个国家团结在一起，那么它就绝对不可能被折断。但当然，它让人联想起古罗马这一事实，对墨索里尼来说，罗马帝国统治了整个地中海，这是一种对失去的意大利伟大状态的提醒。这绝对是吸引力的核心所在。它的奇妙之处在于——正如你提到的，现代的——我认为这相当于是法西斯主义定义的核心。是的，我同意这一点。普尚·拉奥（Prashant Rao）问了这样一个问题：
right to beat those who oppose him. And they're carried on the shoulders of officials called lictors who march around with the magistrate. And the symbolism of the fast jays is that you can break one rod, but if they're bundled up, you can't. And so the appeal of that to Mussolini is evident that if you can join the entire nation together, then it cannot possibly be broken. But of course, the fact that it is redolent of ancient Rome, and for Mussolini, of course, the Roman Empire, which governs the whole Mediterranean is a reminder of a kind of state of lost Italian greatness. That is absolutely kind of fundamental to the appeal. And it's kind of the strangeness of it is, I mean, as you mentioned in your is modern, that I think is pretty fundamental to the definition of fascism. Yeah, I'd agree with that. I mean, Prashant Rao asks this question,
谁是有记载的第一位法西斯分子？我的回答是——也许你会深入研究历史的更深处——但我的回答是，墨索里尼显然是第一位某种程度上的法西斯分子、成功的法西斯领袖。他是那种将法西斯主义变成一个国际品牌，并将其变成一种执政信条而不是对立信条的人。我的意思是，他有前驱。你可能知道露西·休斯-哈利特（Lucy Hughes Hallett）写的那本关于加布里埃尔·邓邓齐奥（Gabriele D'Annunzio）的精彩图书《长矛》（The Pike）。现在，邓邓齐奥是一位诗人，但他也是花花公子、
who was the first recorded fascist? And my answer to that, I mean, maybe you'll delve back into, further back into history, but my answer to that would be Mussolini is obviously the first sort of fascist, successful fascist leader. He is the person who sort of turns fascism into an international brand and who turns it into a governing creed rather than a sort of oppositional one. I mean, he had predecessors. You'll maybe know this brilliant book, The Pike, by Lucy Hughes Hallett about Gabriele D'Annunzio. Now, D'Annunzio was this poet, but he was also a kind of playboy and a
名人和飞行员。他曾领导让意大利加入第一次世界大战的运动。邓邓齐奥预示了我们与墨索里尼联系在一起的所有主题：速度、激情、男子气概、暴力、鲜血，以及对意大利的某种重生——在他看来，意大利是一个失败的国家，是一个新国家，但却是一个失败的国家——通过战争。实际上，我认为在墨索里尼之前，很多历史学家会认可这一点，邓邓齐奥就像是施洗约翰——用你的基督教公式来形容。他是墨索里尼这位弥赛亚的施洗约翰。在第一次世界大战之后，他在阜姆（Fiume）建立了一个准法西斯国家，不是吗？是的，在现在的里耶卡（Rijeka）。我的意思是，他引入了大量后来成为法西斯标志性的东西，包括罗马式敬礼、黑衫军、
celebrity and an aviator. He had led the campaign to get Italy into the First World War. And D'Annunzio anticipated all the themes that we associate with Mussolini about speed, excitement, virility, violence, blood, a sort of rebirth of Italy, which he saw as this failing state, a new state, but a failing state, through war. And I think, actually, before Mussolini, I think a lot of people, historians would buy this, D'Annunzio is the kind of John the Baptist, to use your Christian sort of formula. He is John the Baptist to Mussolini's Messiah. And in the wake of the First World War, he sets up a kind of proto-fascist state in Fiume, doesn't he? He does, in what's now Rijeka. Yes. I mean, and he introduces an awful lot of what will become iconically fascist, including the Roman salute, including the black shirts,
包括在阳台上发表讲话。他非常热衷于给他的敌人喂蓖麻油，这也是墨索里尼非常热衷的事情。所以我想，是的，邓邓齐奥有点像……但正如你所说，他是那个施洗约翰似的人物。但墨索里尼确实是……我的意思是，他是那个披荆斩棘的人，不是吗？所以，是的。
including addresses from balconies. He was very keen on feeding castor oil to his enemies, which was something that Mussolini was very big on as well. So I guess, yeah, D'Onozio is kind of, but he's, as you say, the kind of the John the Baptist figure. But Mussolini really is the, I mean, he's the guy who blazes the path, isn't he? So, well, he is.
但凯尔文——你提到了凯尔文的问题，凯尔文问到了斯巴达人。对。也许我们要讨论这个？不，我想我们现在就应该讨论这个，实际上，因为它就悬在空中。他们回顾的这些人，以任何方式将他们视为准法西斯分子是合理的吗？
But so Kelvin, you mentioned in Kelvin's question, Kelvin asked about the Spartans. Right. Maybe we're going to do this. No, I think we should do this now, actually, because it's hanging there in the air. Are these people that they look back to, is it in any way reasonable
还是这仅仅是将20世纪强加给古代世界？好吧，所以墨索里尼回顾罗马，我的意思是，这在某种程度上是可以理解的，这也是意大利人在罗马帝国崩溃后几乎一直都在做的事情。对于希特勒来说，纳粹主义在某种程度上可以说在质上是不同的。他带给古代历史的视角——我认为古代历史对希特勒和墨索里尼都非常重要——但它再次与某种非常、非常独特的现代事物融合在一起。对希特勒而言，那是一种对达尔文主义的曲解，并强调存在着不同的种族，这些种族处于竞争之中，归根结底你必须强大才能取胜。例如，斯巴达对希特勒的吸引力恰恰在于，希特勒认为它是北欧国家的一个模范。所以希特勒对希腊人和罗马人的看法是，他们是北欧人。
to see them as proto-fascists or is that merely imposing the 20th century onto the ancient world? Well, so Mussolini looking back to Rome, I mean, that's kind of understandable and that's something that Italians have done pretty much since the Roman Empire implodes. For Hitler, and Nazism, I guess, is kind of to a degree qualitatively different. The perspective that he brings to ancient history, and I think ancient history is really important to Hitler as well as to Mussolini, but it's kind of, again, fused with something that is very, very distinctively modern. And for Hitler, that is a kind of garbled sense of Darwinism and an emphasis on the idea that there are different races, that these races are in competition, that ultimately you have to be strong to prevail. And the appeal of Sparta, say, for Hitler is precisely that it is a model, Hitler thinks, of a Nordic state. So Hitler's take on the Greeks and the Romans is that they are Nordic.
斯巴达人是金发碧眼的、身强力壮的。他们臭名昭著地有一种令人作呕的黑汤，希特勒认为它最初来自石勒苏益格-荷尔斯泰因。他真的这么认为吗？这绝对是希特勒的历史观、因而也是未来观的核心：斯巴达人、雅典人、罗马人在他们的伟大时期，基本上都拥有北欧血统。所以当希特勒说斯巴达是历史上最公开的种族主义国家时，他当然是在追溯性地将斯巴达人划归到他那北欧血统的种族主义品牌中。这也是犹太人登场的地方，因为斯巴达发生了什么，雅典发生了什么，罗马发生了什么？当然，它们崩溃了。所以希特勒不得不解释原因。
The Spartans are blonde, are strapping. They notoriously had a revolting black broth that Hitler thought had originally come from Schleswig-Holstein. He genuinely thought this? It was absolutely fundamental to Hitler's sense of history and therefore of the future as well, that the Spartans, the Athenians, the Romans in their greatness were basically from Nordic stock. And so when Hitler says that Sparta is the most transparently racist state in history, he is, of course, retrospectively claiming the Spartans for his Nordic brand of racism. And this is also where the Jews come in, because what happens to Sparta, what happens to Athens, what happens to Rome, of course, they collapse. And so Hitler is obliged to explain why.
他给出的原因是，他们遭到犹太人保罗的世俗普世主义的腐蚀。所以这里存在着一种怪诞的悖论：希特勒最终将犹太人作为种族灭绝目标的原因之一，是他将基督教以及基督教的普世主义归咎于他们。他觉得，你知道的，当他宣告千秋帝国时，它能够持续千年的唯一前景就是它不分享希腊和罗马的命运，如果它不被种族腐蚀，从而崩溃和毁灭。这是一种奇怪的融合：一方面是欧洲历史上贯穿始终的不变元素，即回顾斯巴达人、雅典人、罗马人的榜样；另一方面又与这种
And the reason he gives is that they are corrupted by the cosmopolitan universalism of the Jew Paul. And so there's this kind of grotesque paradox that one of the reasons that Hitler ends up targeting the Jews for genocide is that he is blaming them for Christianity and the universalism of Christianity. And he feels that, you know, that when he proclaims a thousand year Reich, the only prospect of it lasting a thousand years is if it doesn't share in the fate of Greece and Rome, if it doesn't get racially corrupted and therefore collapse and destroyed. And it's this kind of weird fusion of, you know, what has been a constant throughout European history, looking back to the example of the Spartans, the Athenians, the Romans, but fused with this very
非常独特的现代种族理解、适者生存相结合。当然，这两个极端所做的是剔除了基督教，因为你回溯到斯巴达人，又看重达尔文主义。中间的一切都被某种程度上摒弃了。好吧，我认为法西斯主义最迷人的事情之一是，它成功的原因之一在于，像许多成功的政治信条一样，它同时向后看和向前看。因此，那种古代图像学和那种对古代历史的发明，正如你刚才所说的，与所有这些关于
distinctively modern understanding of race, of the survival of the fittest. And of course, what those two extremes do is to excise Christianity, because you're looking back to the Spartans, and you're looking to Darwinism. Everything in between is kind of dismissed. Well, one of the fascinating things about fascism, I think, is that one of the reasons it was successful is that, like a lot of successful political creeds, it looks simultaneously backwards and forwards. So that sort of ancient iconography and that sort of invention of an ancient history goes hand in hand, as you said earlier, with all this stuff that sort of ancient iconography and that sort of invention of an ancient history goes hand in hand as you said earlier with all this stuff about sort of um planes and flight
飞机、飞行和技术的宏大叙事齐头并进。法西斯主义被视为……我的意思是，上世纪20和30年代年轻人之所以被法西斯主义吸引的原因之一，是因为它看起来很酷，显得现代而崭新。他们经常谈论那些管理着民主政体的老头子们。正是这种法西斯主义的双重面孔，让它变得如此引人入胜。那就是，你知道的，他们在采用古老的()));
and technology which fascism was seen to i mean one of the reasons that young people in particular were attracted to fascism in the 1920s and 30s was because it seemed cool and it was seemed modern and new and they often talked about the old men who were running democracies. And it's that sort of double-facing side of fascism that makes it sort of so interesting. That it's, you know, they're taking old myths, but they are dreaming of a new world. And I guess you would say that that's one thing
神话，但他们在梦想一个新世界。我想你会说，那是它与共产主义的一个共同点，即对新事物的梦想，不是吗？它并非植根于——可以说是——新事物，不是吗？它不植根于——可以说是——此时此地，它总是渴望着这种乌托邦，但它是……它有一种迷人的魅力，就像
that has in common with communism, is that dream of the new, isn't it? That it's not rooted in, as it were, the new isn't it that it's it's not rooted in as it were in the here and now it's sort of always aspiring to this sort of utopia but it's um it's it's glamorous in the way that um extremely violent films are glamorous um brutality and war and violence are glamorous to people um yeah i mean there's a famous um comment that um Woolf made, who obviously is not someone you would associate
极端暴力电影具有的那种魅力一样。残暴、战争和暴力对人们来说具有某种魅力……是的，我的意思是，伍尔夫（Woolf）曾有一句著名的评论，她显然不是那种你会与暴力的魅力联系在一起的人。但在1940年5月，当她看着德军的成功时，她说他们看起来是那么年轻，那么有活力，那么充满生机。是的。而我们看起来却步履蹒跚、老态龙钟。正如你所说，那种法西斯主义——我想特别是纳粹主义——是未来的感觉，
with the glamour of violence. But in May 1940, when she's looking at the success of the German armies, and she says that they seem so young, they seem so vigorous, they seem so alive. Yeah. And we look plodding and old. And as you say, that sense that fascism, and I guess particularly Nazism, was kind of the future,
就像一朵阴影一样笼罩着30年代的自由民主捍卫者。哦，在20和30年代，你随时都能看到这种现象。人们在哀叹并说道，民主政体……他们不知道我们所知道的事，所以他们并不知道民主将会持久。许多人确实认为，特别是在墨索里尼开始入侵别人之前，
was something that kind of hung like a shadow over defenders of liberal democracy in the 30s. Oh, in the 20s and 30s, you see that all the time. People lamenting and saying, is democracy... They don't know what we know, so they don't know that democracy will endure. A lot of people did think, and particularly before Mussolini started invading people,
所以在20年代，我的意思是，墨索里尼得到了来自政治光谱各方人们的极高赞誉。他们说，哦，他搞了很多公共工程。他是一个非常有男子气概的家伙。丘吉尔访问过墨索里尼。是的，丘吉尔称赞过墨索里尼。因为如果他是意大利人，他就会是个法西斯分子。绝对是的。
so in the 20s, I mean, Mussolini got a lot of praise from people on all sides of the political spectrum. He said, oh, he does a lot of public works. He's a very manly fellow. Churchill visited Mussolini. Yeah, Churchill praised Mussolini. Because if he was Italian, he would have been a fascist. Absolutely.
这有时被用来当作棍棒来打击丘吉尔，说他搞错了。但在丘吉尔微不足道的辩护中，许多人在20世纪20年代都对法西斯主义说过这样的话。我的意思是，当新的美国政府最终赢得战争、罗斯福政府在1932-33年上台时，他们派人去意大利考察意大利人是如何开展公共工程、修建道路以及诸如此类的各种事情的，
And that's sometimes used as a stick to beat Churchill with, that he got that wrong. But in Churchill's sort of slight defence, lots of people said things like that about fascism in the 1920s. I mean, when the new American administration ends up winning the war, the Roosevelt administration comes in in 1932-33, they send people to Italy to go and look at how Italians are doing public works and building roads and all this kind of stuff,
去看看意大利的法西斯主义是如何运作的，因为他们认为这可能有一些他们在美国的新政（New Deal）中可以使用的点子。从那以后，那些讨厌新政的人——也就是非常、非常右翼的美国人——就会说，哦，它实际上在灵感上是法西斯主义的，这并不是真的。但确实，在那之前，法西斯主义并没有完全……当然它仍然是暴力的，但并没有完全带有在希特勒上台后才获得的独特道德污点。但我猜法西斯主义仍然拥有一种诱惑力和魅力，即使那是邪恶的魅力。我的意思是，我认为我们在这个话题上有这么多的提问，表明了这种吸引力的一部分（你知道的，邪恶其实很有魅力）。所以我们有两个问题，
to look at how Italian fascism works, because they think it may have some ideas that they can use in the New Deal in America. And since then, sort of people who hate the New Deal, so very, very right wing Americans say, oh, well, it's really fascist and inspiration, which isn't true. But it's true that up to that point, fascism didn't quite, it was still violent, of course, but didn't quite have that sort of uniquely sort of moral taint that it was to get after Hitler comes to power. But I guess what fascism does still have is a kind of allure and glamour, even if it's the glamour of evil. I mean, I think the fact that we've had so many questions on this topic suggests that part of the fascination, you know, evil is kind of glamorous. And so we've got two questions
来了解意大利法西斯主义是如何运作的，因为他们认为法西斯主义可能有一些他们可以在美国的“新政”中借鉴的想法。从那时起，那些厌恶“新政”的人，也就是非常非常右翼的美国人，就说，哦，它实际上带有法西斯主义的启发，但这并不是真的。不过确实，在那之前，法西斯主义虽然当然还是很暴力，但还没有那种在希特勒上台后才获得的独特道德污点。但我想法西斯主义依然具有某种吸引力和魅力，哪怕那是邪恶的魅力。我的意思是，我认为我们收到这么多关于这个话题的提问，表明这种迷恋的一部分原因在于，你知道，邪恶其实是有一种魅力的。所以我们有两个问题
that I think are not kind of flippant i think i mean i think they're actually really important one from i hope i'm pronouncing his or her name right mac maith mac matthew um who asks why were shirt colors such a big deal for mid-20th century fascists and with another question from christian what's with the uniforms and actually the uniforms are really important aren aren't they? I mean, beginning with the nuncio and the black shirts. They're massively important. I mean, I think what you have to do with the uniforms is you have to see them in context. So in a world in which a lot of people are wearing uniforms, and this will
我认为它们并不是轻率的，我认为它们实际上非常重要。一个来自——希望我没有发错他或她的名字——麦克·马思·麦克·马修（Mac Maith Mac Matthew），他问：为什么衬衫颜色对20世纪中期的法西斯分子来说是一件大事？以及克里斯蒂安（Christian）提出的另一个问题：制服是怎么回事？实际上，制服真的很重要，不是吗？我的意思是，从邓邓齐奥和黑衫军开始。它们极其重要。我的意思是，我认为你对待制服的态度，你必须把它们放在背景中来看。所以在一个许多人都穿着制服的世界里，这
sound to many people as sort of incredibly trite and silly thing to say, but this is a world in which, you know, thousands and thousands of youngsters every year are joining the boy scouts and joining groups that where you dress up in uniforms in military type kind of costumes so the boy scouts had sort of come you know edwardian so around about the same time as as people the first sort of fascist sort of stirrings are getting underway then you have the first world war So lots of people are in uniform. And then there are a lot of paramilitary movements at the end of the First World War. And so you're living in a world in which a lot of people have been wearing uniforms and liked wearing them. It gave them a sense of belonging and a sense of identity.
对许多人来说听起来像是一句极其陈腐和愚蠢的话，但这是一个世界，在这个世界里，成千上万的年轻人每年都加入童子军，加入那些让你穿上军服式服装的组织。所以童子军大约在爱德华时代兴起——差不多就在第一批法西斯萌芽开始形成的同一时期，然后就是第一次世界大战。所以很多人都穿过军服。然后在第一次世界大战结束时有许多准军事运动。所以你生活在一个很多人都穿过军服并且喜欢穿军服的世界里。这给了他们一种归属感和认同感。
And it's part of Mussolini's sort of evil genius that he pushes the uniforms. And of course, Hitler does that later on when the nazi party starts the party is structured in a military kind of way and there are sort of ranks and different kinds of uniforms and all the rest of it and that gives it a sort of it anchors it in that world in a way that people understand and of course as you know what's sort of hanging over this is that to a lot of people at the time, the uniforms looked cool. They wanted to wear them. I mean, that's a terrible thing to say, but it's true.
而推崇制服是墨索里尼某种邪恶天才的一部分。当然，希特勒在纳粹党开始运作后也这样做了——纳粹党的结构是军事化的，有军阶和各种不同的制服等等。这赋予了它一种……它以一种人们能理解的方式将其扎根于那个世界。当然，正如你所知，悬在这一切头上的是，对于当时的许多人来说，制服看起来很酷。他们想穿。我的意思是，这是一件可怕的话题，但这是事实。
And even now, you know, children, for example, have a fascination with the Nazis because they see them as they do with the forces of evil in Star Wars. They all have their ranks and they all have different helmets and they all have their different insignia. And that has a kind of weird hold over us, doesn't it? But I mean, you mentioned the Boy Scouts and Baden-Powell was kind of fascinated by Hitler. Yeah. Pretty much up to up to the start of the war. But there is also this kind of um kind of modernism uh poetry uh you know the kind of figures of uh that denunzio represents so that is also part of it and denunzio who's a kind of famous dandy um you know he's he's he's not just a poet he looks like a poet he does kind of glamorous things in a kind of byronic style
甚至现在，你知道的，孩子们，例如，对纳粹有一种着迷，就像他们对《星球大战》中的邪恶势力一样。他们都有自己的军阶，都有不同的头盔，都有不同的徽章。这在我们身上有一种奇怪的控制力，不是吗？但我的意思是，你提到了童子军，贝登堡（Baden-Powell）曾对希特勒着迷。是的，差不多直到战争开始。但这里也有这种……现代主义、诗意……你知道的，邓邓齐奥所代表的那种人物，所以这也是其中的一部分。邓邓齐奥是一个著名的花花公子，
and so it's kind of telling i I think, that he is the guy who invents the black shirt, because he obviously has the aesthetic sense to that, I suppose, particularly in the Mediterranean Sun, perhaps it has a kind of particular quality of menace and glamour that really makes it stand out. Just looks shabby when Oswald Mosley does it. You're right. And actually, Maya asked a question about that on Twitter. She said, can you discuss why so many modernist writers were attracted to fascism and fascism's general influence on the arts um and that's that's part of the set that's almost part of the same topic as the as the uniforms because you're right it's a poet who comes up with the uniforms
你知道的，他不仅仅是一个诗人，他看起来就像一个诗人，他以一种拜伦式的风格做着各种迷人的事情。所以这很有说明意义，我认为，他是发明黑衫军的人，因为他显然有那种美学感，我想，特别是在地中海的阳光下，它或许有一种特殊的威胁感和魅力，真正让它脱颖而出。当奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利（Oswald Mosley）穿上它时，看起来就很破旧。你说得对。事实上，玛雅（Maya）在推特上问了一个关于这方面的问题。她说：你能讨论一下为什么那么多现代主义作家会被法西斯主义吸引，以及法西斯主义对艺术的总体影响吗？这几乎是与制服相同主题的一部分，因为你说得对，是一个诗人发明了制服。
and you know modernism literary modernism or cultural modernism was all about excitement and style and breaking with the past and creating something new. And an intolerance of what they saw as the sort of the fusty old men with all their fudges and compromises. Wing collars and umbrellas. Exactly that. So if you've ever read this sort of, I mean, God knows who reads these things for pleasure but the italian futurist poets of the 1910s their stuff is all about you know smashing destroying isn't it destroy venice that's sort of the the beauty of the punch all this kind of stuff that just seems now like the kind of thing a 17 year old boy writes in his bedroom because he's never you know he doesn't know how to talk to any girls and he's feeling very miserable. That sort of literary aesthetic explains, I think, why a lot of intelligent, otherwise intelligent people, kind of Wyndham Lewis type people, poets and stuff,
并且，你知道的，现代主义、文学现代主义或文化现代主义，全部都是关于兴奋、风格、与过去决裂以及创造新事物的。以及对他们所认为的那些因循守旧、充满权宜之计和妥协的老头子的不宽容。硬领衬衫和雨伞。正是如此。所以，如果你读过这种——天知道谁会为了消遣读这些东西——1910年代的意大利未来主义诗人的作品，他们的东西全都是关于粉碎、摧毁的，不是吗？“摧毁威尼斯”，诸如此类关于通心粉的美学，所有这些现在看起来只像是一个17岁男孩在卧室里写的东西，因为他从来——你知道的——他不知道怎么跟女孩说话，而且他感觉非常悲惨。这种文学美学解释了，我认为，为什么许多聪明、原本聪明的人，温德姆·刘易斯（Wyndham Lewis）类型的人、诗人们，会
flirted with fascism because they thought it was cool, exciting, radical, new, as opposed to, as you say, the sort of tweedeedy yeah collary sort of world of the edwardians and we must come to a break in a minute but just to just to add to that another crucial figure who's not a pervert a philosopher is nietzsche um mussolini is a great admirer of nietzsche nietzsche essentially proclaims i mean he he basically is the philosopher who dismisses christianity as sapping innovating get rid of it. And he says that with the death of God, a new order will emerge in which the blonde beast is released. It will be a time of great convulsions. And Mussolini absolutely picks up on this. I mean,
调情于法西斯主义，因为他们认为它很酷、令人兴奋、激进而崭新，而不是像你所说的爱德华时代那种温和的、有领子的世界。我们马上要休息一下，但为了补充这一点，另一个至关重要的人物不是色情狂，而是一位哲学家，尼采。墨索里尼是尼采的狂热崇拜者。尼采本质上宣称——他基本上就是那个将基督教贬低为削弱活力、革除活力的哲学家，摆脱它吧。他说，随着上帝之死，将出现一个新的秩序，在这个秩序中，“金发野兽”将被释放。这将是一个发生巨大动荡的时代。而墨索里尼绝对接受了这一点。我的意思是，
Mussolini is writing about Nietzsche before the First World War. And although Nietzsche was kind of very, very hostile to German nationalism, really hostile, became a kind of stateless person, even so you can see in Hitler's perspective on history, his attitudes to classical antiquity, to Christianity, to Judaism, that there is a kind of garbled understanding of Nietzsche there. So I think that also is part of this kind of fascist mix. But I think on that note, we must go for a break. So much to talk about. We will continue. I'm going to go and iron my black shirt. And yes, be tuned in a second. Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to
墨索里尼在第一次世界大战之前就在撰写关于尼采的文章。尽管尼采对德国民族主义非常、非常敌视，真的敌视，成了一个无国籍的人，但即便如此，你依然可以在希特勒的历史观、他对古典古代、基督教、犹太教的态度中，看到其中有一种对尼采的曲解。所以这也是这种法西斯混合体的一部分。但基于这一点，我们必须去休息一下。有太多要谈的了。我们将继续。我要去熨我的黑衫军。是的，稍后收听。海德（Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目和抢先购买现场票的机会，请访问
therestisentertainment.com. That's th Is History. We've pressed our uniforms. We're ready to go. Tom, I'm going to ask you a question. And I think what we should do, Tom, is get through loads of the questions because we've got so many. I think we got through about two in the first half and we've got only about 500 to go. So let's see how many we can do. Chris Cope, I'm going to kick off with Chris Cope. Chris Cope says, are there any regimes today which would meet your definition of being fascist? Have you got any nominations? I don't think there are, because I think, as we've been talking, I think fascism is an expression of particular confluence of circumstances that essentially was brought to an end with the Second World War, with the deaths of Mussolini and Hitler. So, no, I don't think there are any.
therestisentertainment.com。那是……是历史。我们已经熨好了制服。我们准备好出发了。汤姆，我要问你一个问题。我想我们应该做的是，汤姆，回答大量的提问题，因为我们有太多问题了。我想我们在上半场只回答了大约两个，而我们还有大约500个要回答。所以让我们看看我们能回答多少。克里斯·科普（Chris Cope），我要从克里斯·科普开始。克里斯·科普说：当今是否有任何政权符合你们对法西斯主义的定义？你有任何提名吗？我认为没有，因为正如我们一直在谈论的那样，我认为法西斯主义是特定情况交汇的表现，随着第二次世界大战的结束、墨索里尼和希特勒的死亡，这种表现基本上走到了尽头。所以，不，我认为没有。
What do you think? You've maybe got a finger on the pulse of contemporary politics. Of course I do. Of course I do. No, probably not. I mean, for example, people might say Vladimir Putin is a fascist, but he's not a fascist. He doesn't believe in... He doesn't have a totalitarian regime. He doesn't believe in creating a new kind of society.
你怎么看？你也许对当代政治的脉搏有所把握。我当然有。我当然有。不，可能没有。例如，人们可能会说弗拉基米尔·普京是法西斯分子，但他不是法西斯分子。他不相信……他没有一个极权政体。他不相信创造一种新社会。
He's an authoritarian, you know, he's an authoritarian kind of nationalist, but that's not the same as being a fascist. I think people often sort of muddy those things. So I'd probably agree with you, no. Okay, well, there's another question here from, definitely for donald from harold wilson oh harold and uh harold wilson is asking does salazar and franco fit into the same mold as hitler or are they different in a substantive way so again this this is really kind of focusing on the question is is anyone who is a dictator fascist is it to be a dictator and a fascist, is that synonymous?
他是一个威权主义者，你知道的，他是一个威权主义的民族主义者，但这与成为法西斯分子是不同的。人们经常把这些事情搞混。所以我大概会同意你的看法，没有。好吧，这里还有另一个问题，绝对是给多米尼克的，来自哈罗德·威尔逊（Harold Wilson）。哦，哈罗德。哈罗德·威尔逊问：萨拉查（Salazar）和弗朗哥（Franco）符合希特勒的模式吗？还是他们在实质上有很大不同？所以，这实际上非常聚焦于这个问题：任何独裁者都是法西斯分子吗？成为一个独裁者和一个法西斯分子，这两者是同义词吗？
Well, I knew Harold Dawson would ask a good question. And that is a great question. It's one that's very popular. So I don't think Salazar, who's Portugal and Franco, who's Spain, are fascists. They both flirt with elements of fascism, but they both actually end up, particularly Salazar, suppressing their local fascist parties after sort of flirting with them. They're both authoritarians, and they're slightly, you know, they have good relationships with Mussolini and Hitler, but the big difference is Salazar and Franco just want
嗯，我知道哈罗德·威尔逊会问一个好问题。那真是一个好问题。这是一个非常受欢迎的问题。所以，我不认为萨拉查（葡萄牙的）和弗朗哥（西班牙的）是法西斯分子。他们都曾与法西斯主义的元素眉来眼去，但实际上他们俩最终都——特别是萨拉查——在与当地的法西斯政党调情之后将其镇压了。他们都是威权主义者，而且他们稍微……你知道的，他们与墨索里尼和希特勒保持着良好的关系，但最大的区别在于萨拉查和弗朗哥只想
to freeze their societies in aspic. They want to preserve the kind of very Catholic, conservative, landowner-dominated worlds of 19th century Portugal and Spain. They don't want to create anything new. They're not into the technology. They don't like big meetings of people. They don't like youngsters sort of expressing themselves and excitement and speed. They want everything to be stuck. And that's the difference. They're not fascists in that sense. So they're reactionaries. Exactly. They're pure authoritarian reactionaries. And fascism may have reactionary elements and may do deals with reactionary people.
将他们的社会冻结在琥珀中。他们想要保护19世纪葡萄牙和西班牙那种高度天主教的、保守的、由地主支配的世界。他们不想创造任何新东西。他们不热衷于技术。他们不喜欢大规模的人群集会。他们不喜欢年轻人表现自己、追求兴奋和速度。他们希望一切都停滞不前。这就是区别。从这个意义上说，他们不是法西斯分子。所以他们是反动派。完全正确。他们是纯粹的威权反动派。法西斯主义可能具有反动元素，也可能与反动派进行交易，
So Hitler and Mussolini both did deals with conservative elites, but they were radicals. I mean, that's the interesting thing, that Mussolini started way on the left. He was a sort of radical socialist who then basically rebranded himself. But that's the great theme of the John Lukacs book on the duel about Hitler and Churchill, that Churchill is a reactionary, Churchill is a kind of embodiment of an order that seems antiquated compared to Hitler, who is absolutely seems, you know, in the summer of 1940 to be the embodiment of the future. And I, you know, I really summer of 1940 to be the embodiment of the future. And I, you know, I really do think that Hitler
因此希特勒和墨索里尼都与保守精英达成过交易，但他们是激进分子。我的意思是，有趣的是，墨索里尼最初是在左翼起家的。他是一种激进的社会主义者，后来基本上给自己重新进行了品牌重塑。但那是约翰·卢卡斯（John Lukacs）关于希特勒和丘吉尔对决的书中的伟大主题：丘吉尔是一个反动派，丘吉尔是某种秩序的化身，与在1940年夏天绝对显得是未来化身的希特勒相比，这种秩序显得过时了。而且我，你知道，我真的
is the most revolutionary figure in European history. I think he pushes, you know, he tramples down more that Europeans over the course of the past thousand years have taken for granted than any other figure in European history. Whereas, as you say, you know, Franco is, I mean, he makes the Virgin Mary a kind of an official in his regime, doesn't he? Yeah, I mean, that's the interesting thing about Salazar.
认为希特勒是欧洲历史上最具革命性的人物。我认为他推动了……他践踏了过去一千年来欧洲人认为理所当然的更多的东西，超过了欧洲历史上的任何其他人。然而，正如你所说，你知道，弗朗哥是——我的意思是，他让圣母玛利亚成为他政权的一名官员，不是吗？是的，我的意思是，关于萨拉查，有趣的是……
I mean, if you look at Salazar and Franco, Salazar was an economics professor, a very highly respected economics professor in Portugal. Franco was a general in the Spanish army. So they're both, you know, by their own lights, successful people. Mussolini, as Churchill was, of course, you know, descended from an aristocratic family, very successful politician. So they've got a stake in the system. Mussolini and Hitler were both outsiders. I mean, Hitler was a complete and utter nobody and a failure. So of course he wants to smash everything and revolutionize everything. Because to him, the old world is associated with failure and misery and loneliness and all these kinds of things and that's why his regime has an appeal to people who
如果你看看萨拉查和弗朗哥，萨拉查是一位经济学教授，是葡萄牙一位备受尊敬的经济学教授。弗朗哥是西班牙军队的一名将军。所以他们俩，你知道的，按他们自己的标准来看，都是成功人士。墨索里尼——当然正如丘吉尔那样——出身于贵族家庭，是一位非常成功的政治家。所以他们在体制内拥有既得利益。而墨索里尼和希特勒都是局外人。我的意思是，希特勒完全是一个无名小卒和失败者。所以当然他想砸碎一切、革新一切。因为对他来说，旧世界与失败、痛苦、孤独以及所有这类事情联系在一起，这就是为什么他的政权对那些
who share that that view and his that genius of both muslim and hitler is to win all those people who are kind of losers if you like but also to win over and to do deals with the people who already have a stake the landowners and stuff. Can I follow that up with a question from John Delay, which I do not feel qualified to answer, but you I'm sure do. And he asks, was fascism a revolution of the middle class? I think there's probably a lot of truth in that. So fascism often appealed to people who are kind of lower middle class or very upper working class, sort of respectable type people.
有这种观点的人具有吸引力。墨索里尼和希特勒的天才之处在于，既能赢得所有那些可以说是失败者的人，又能赢得并与那些已经在体制内拥有既得利益的人——比如地主之流——达成交易。我能接着问一个来自约翰·德莱（John Delay）的问题吗？我觉得自己没有资格回答，但我确信你有。他问：法西斯主义是中产阶级的革命吗？我认为这其中可能有很多真相。因此，法西斯主义通常吸引那些属于下中产阶级或上层工人阶级、有点体面类型的人。
And it's basically an antidote to communism. So that's something we haven't really talked about, Tom, is how much fascism is created as a kind of mirror image of communism. No communism, I think no fascism. So people are drawn, the societies in which people are drawn to fascism tend to be ones where people are very, very worried about a red revolution. And that's obviously one reason why it starts in the 20s after the russian revolution but also is it i mean it both both emerge from um a climate of violence in which it's taken for granted that you um that opportunities for settling differences through democratic means um through liberal means are simply not there and so if you um you know if you're if you're a communist beating up a fascist
它基本上是共产主义的解药。所以这是我们还没有真正讨论过的事情，汤姆：法西斯主义在多大程度上是作为共产主义的镜像创造出来的。没有共产主义，我认为就没有法西斯主义。所以人们被吸引、人们被吸引到法西斯主义的那些社会，往往是人们非常、非常担心红色革命的社会。这显然是它在20世纪20年代俄国革命后开始的原因之一，但同时它也是……它是否……这两者都从……
and if you're a fascist beating up a communist in a sense you have a kind of um mutual relationship there because both of you are serving to to rot the foundations of the liberal order that um otherwise would would regard both of you as the enemy so there is a kind of um absolutely i think that's absolutely right. You're both playing the same game, aren't you? You want to smash the system. And you hate all the sort of the liberal politicians who are compromising and making coalitions and all this sort of stuff. And actually, that's what... Hitler comes to power in part, I think, because the depression drives more and more people towards the extremes. So they think, well, the middle ground has failed. I have to choose one of these two alternatives.
一种暴力气候中萌生，在这种气候中，你理所当然地认为你……通过民主手段——通过自由手段解决分歧的机会根本不存在。所以如果你……你知道的，如果你是一个殴打法西斯分子的共产主义者，而你是一个殴打共产主义者的法西斯分子，从某种意义上说，你们之间有一种……互惠的关系，因为你们俩都在努力破坏自由主义秩序的基础——这种秩序在其他情况下会把你们两个都视为敌人。所以存在着一种……绝对的，我认为这完全正确。你们俩都在玩同一个游戏，不是吗？你们想粉碎这个体制。而且你们痛恨所有那些妥协、组建联合政府之类的自由派政客。实际上，这就是……希特勒掌权的部分原因，我认为，是因为大萧条把越来越多的人推向了极端。所以他们想，好吧，中间派已经失败了。我必须在这两个选择中做出一个。
And there are more people who will choose Nazism than there are communism. Right. Okay. So let's follow up that with a question from Michael Rush, who asks, why do we see fascism as the worst political movement in history, but communism is always seen as a noble cause, even though it has killed 100 million? Is it because we think in Western thoughts, and as communism didn't take over the West, like it did Eastern Europe, it's better? Well, it won't surprise you to hear that again, I think this is to be explained by the Christian context, because fascism, as I said, is, I think, more profoundly revolutionary than communism, because communism, although it overturns kings and churches and so
而且选择纳粹主义的人比选择共产主义的人更多。对吧。好吧。那么我们接下来看迈克尔·拉什（Michael Rush）提出的一个问题，他问：为什么我们认为法西斯主义是历史上最糟糕的政治运动，而共产主义却总被视为一种崇高的事业，尽管它杀害了一亿人？是因为我们以西方思维思考，而且由于共产主义没有像在东欧那样接管西方，所以它更好吗？嗯，听到我再次这样说，你可能不会感到惊讶，我认为这要从基督教的语境来解释，因为正如我所说，法西斯主义我认为比共产主义更具根本性的革命性，因为共产主义，虽然它推翻了国王、教会等等，
on, it does so for reasons that goes with the grain of Christian history, the conviction that the poor shall inherit the earth, that the first shall be last, that at the end of Christian history, the conviction that the poor shall inherit the earth, that the first shall be last, that at the end of days, a new Jerusalem will descend on the earth. And the worker's paradise is a kind of essentially a riff on utopianism that we see throughout the course of Christian history, whereas fascism overtly goes against that. Fascism says that the weak should essentially be crushed and that racism is a moral good. And we find that profoundly offensive in a way that we tend not to find communism. You know, Tom, I sometimes shake my head and roll my eyes at your Christian stuff, but I actually buy that. I think that's a really good... I hope they cut this out,
但它这样做的原因符合基督教历史的内核——坚信穷人必将承受地府，温顺的人将承受土地，最后的将成为最先的，在基督教历史的终结之时，新耶路撒冷将降临人间。而工人天堂本质上是对我们在整个基督教历史中都能看到的乌托邦主义的一种变奏，而法西斯主义则公然违背了这一点。法西斯主义认为弱者本质上应该被粉碎，种族主义是一种道德上的善。我们对这一点感到深深的冒犯，而对共产主义往往不会有这种感觉。你知道，汤姆，有时我对你那些基督教的东西感到摇头叹息，但我其实接受这一点。我认为这是一个非常好的……我希望他们把这段剪掉，
but I actually think that's a very good argument. Because it's obvious that that sort of well-meaning kind of, for want to use a sort of Daily Mail-ish word, bien pensant people, sort of wince at anti-communism, don't they? They think, oh, well, communism wasn't so bad. They built nice nursery schools or, you know, there's a sort of...
但我实际上认为这是一个非常好的论点。因为很明显，那种好心的、为了用一个有点《每日邮报》风格的词，那些“bien pensant”（自以为是的精英）对反共主义感到畏缩，不是吗？他们会想，哦，好吧，共产主义其实没那么坏。他们建造了漂亮的幼儿园，或者，你知道，有一种……
Yes, yes. That sort of utopianism plays well, doesn't schools or you know there's a sort of yes yes that sort of utopianism plays well doesn't it yeah there's a kind of unspoken feeling that that that killing 10 million people you know in the cause of establishing a worker's paradise is less bad than killing 10 million people because you're a racist yeah i think that is fundamentally the idea and i think also that the idea is is pretty strong that punching a nazi in the face is better than a nazi punching uh an anti-fascist protester in the face yeah you see but both are violent but but one form of violence is morally better than the other you see that on twitter all the time don't you people say oh you should you should punch nazis or you only defeat fascists by sort of confronting them and all this sort of there's
对，对。那种乌托邦主义很受欢迎，不是吗……学校或者你知道，有一种……对，对，那种乌托邦主义很受欢迎，不是吗？是的，有一种心照不宣的感觉，为了建立工人天堂而杀死一千万人，比因为你是种族主义者而杀死一千万人要不那么糟糕。是的，我认为这基本上就是那种想法。而且我认为，这种想法也很强烈：打一个纳粹的脸，比纳粹打反法西斯抗议者的脸要好。是的，你看，但两者都是暴力的，不过一种暴力在道德上比另一种更好。你在推特上随时都能看到这种现象，不是吗？人们说，哦，你应该，你应该打纳粹，或者你只能通过对抗他们来击败法西斯，诸如此类，有……
that there are there is a slight element i think of double standards one other thing i'd add there actually he asked about eastern europe and western europe and i think michael rush and i think that sorry it's actually michelle rush um michelle unless we've got a unless we've got a excuse um uh but michelle or michael I think is right that in Eastern Europe, it is remembered a bit differently. I mean, I don't know if you've ever been to these sort of museums that you'll see in the Baltic States or in Hungary or in the Czech Republic, where they'll often treat the occupations by the Nazis and the communists
这其中存在一点双重标准的成分，我认为。我还想补充的一点是，他刚才提到了东欧和西欧，迈克尔·拉什——哦抱歉，其实是米歇尔·拉什（Michelle Rush），米歇尔，除非我们搞错了——但米歇尔或迈克尔，我认为在东欧，人们对它的记忆确实有点不同。我的意思是，我不知道你有没有去过波罗的海国家、匈牙利或捷克共和国的那些博物馆，在那里，他们通常会把纳粹和共产主义者的占领……
sort of side by side. And it's, you know, you get a sense of them seeing the two things as completely equivalent and i can actually remember being in on holiday in bulgaria and a man selling having a big tray in a in this sort of village had this big tray full of um communist memorabilia you know badges and so my friend and i stopped and were looking at all this sort of stuff and then he said oh you're english I have a special tray. And he got out his special tray.
放在一起相提并论。你会感觉到他们把这两者看作是完全等同的。我甚至记得在保加利亚度假时，在一个村子里，一个卖东西的人推着一个大托盘，盘里全都是共产主义的纪念品，你知道，徽章什么的。于是我和朋友停下来看这些东西，然后他说，哦，你是英国人，我有一个特殊的托盘。接着他拿出了他的那个特殊托盘。
And that was full of SS memorabilia. And we were sort of, you see, we were shocked. I mean, oh, that's terrible. He's got all this SS memorabilia. We were just looking at the KGB stuff. As though, and of course, at that point, I thought, that's so interesting. That that's our instinctive reaction. That the KGB stuff, you can sort of engage engage in ironically as a Brit in the 1990s.
那里面装满了党卫军（SS）的纪念品。当时我们有点……你知道，我们震惊了。我的意思是，天哪，太可怕了，他有这么多党卫军的纪念品！而我们刚才只是在看克格勃（KGB）的东西。就好像——当然，在那一刻我想，这太有趣了，这就是我们的本能反应：克格勃的东西，作为一个20世纪90年代的英国人，你似乎可以带有一种讽刺的眼光去看待它，
But the SS stuff is you can't. It's beyond the pale. It's unacceptable. And I guess we do have a kind of double standard in Britain that people might not have if they had lived through, you know, under the Iron Curtain. Right. Well, on the top again, going with the theme of communism and fascism here's one from jim longhurst who asks um here's one to get you cancelled before january is through um it's 1930 would you rather live in fascist italy or soviet russia i'm going to broaden that out would you rather live in fascist italy um democratic as it is then Weimar Germany or Soviet Russia? Whose history would you want to live through in the 30s?
但党卫军的东西却不行。那是不可逾越的底线，是不可接受的。我想我们在英国确实有一种双重标准，如果人们不是在铁幕下生活过的话，可能就不会有这种标准。好啦，言归正传，顺着共产主义和法西斯的这个主题，这里有一个来自吉姆·朗赫斯特（Jim Longhurst）的问题，他问：嗯，这个问题能让你在1月过完之前就被取消资格——现在是1930年，你更愿意生活在法西斯意大利还是苏维埃俄国？我把它扩大一下：你更愿意生活在法西斯意大利、当时的民主魏玛德国，还是苏维埃俄国？在30年代，你愿意经历谁的历史？
I mean, I suppose it depends. You know, are you a Jew? Yeah, this is really the... Are you a member of the bourgeoisie? This is sort of a David Starkey moment, isn't it? I think... It's got to be fascist Italy, hasn't it? So I was going to say, yeah, I'm sort of...
我的意思是，我想这得看情况。你知道，你是犹太人吗？是的，这真的是……你是资产阶级的一员吗？这有点像大卫·斯塔基（David Starkey）的时刻，不是吗？我认为……那一定是非斯意大利，对吧？所以我正要说，是的，我有点……
It clearly is. The least murderous of those societies is fascist Italy, not least because Mussolini was quite incompetent. So assuming that you're sort of in the middle of the... in the sort of middle of the social spectrum, you're probably less likely to be killed in fascist Italy. That's a terrible thing to say. But Soviet Russia, I mean, of course,
显然是的。这些社会中杀戮最少的是法西斯意大利，不仅仅是因为墨索里尼相当无能。所以假设你处于社会阶层的中间，你在法西斯意大利被杀的可能性可能会小一些。这话真难听。但是苏维埃俄国，我的意思是，当然，
the more keen and eager a member of the party you are, the more likely Stalin's going to kill you. So I don't think Soviet Russia is a bundle of laughs. But also you've got the war coming up. And terrible, though, Italy's experience of the war was, I guess it's not as bad as Germany's or Russia's or Germany so um yeah I go on yeah I mean that's quite a sort of miserable question isn't it but um yeah glad I wasn't born in any of them um do we have another
你作为党内成员越狂热、越积极，斯大林杀你的可能性就越大。所以我不认为苏维埃俄国是个充满欢笑的地方。而且你还要面临即将到来的战争。虽然意大利的战争经历很糟糕，但我想它没有德国、俄国或德国那么糟，所以……嗯，我继续说，我的意思是，这是一个相当悲惨的问题，不是吗？不过……嗯，庆幸我没有出生在其中任何一个国家。我们还有另一个……
question yeah let's uh so Peter Harpley um I'm just looking down the same page actually but Peter Harpley's got a good question about Napoleon. So there's lots of parallels between Hitler and Stalin. And he says, is there a parallel as well between Hitler and Napoleon? Hubris brought them down. Of course, they're both world conquerors. They both devise new systems. They redraw boundaries.
问题吗？是的，让我们……所以彼得·哈普利（Peter Harpley）——其实我正看着同一页——彼得·哈普利有一个关于拿破仑的好问题。希特勒和斯大林之间有很多相似之处。他说，希特勒和拿破仑之间是否存在相似之处？傲慢使他们垮台。当然，他们都是世界征服者。他们都设计了新的体系。他们重新划定了边界。
Do you think there's any comparison there, Tom? They both failed to conquer Britain. They did, and both went to russia um notoriously yeah um so what do you think napoleon no no no no i i don't he likes a uniform to reiterate i think i think that fascism is bred of very specific circumstances. And so I think that to associate fascism with just conquering Europe, say, or having fascists or whatever is inadequate. Clearly, Hitler and Mussolini draw on elements from history to spice up their look, their brand, their image. But at the same time, they are inimitably 20th century
汤姆，你觉得这里面有什么可比性吗？他们都未能征服英国。确实，而且都去了俄国……臭名昭著，是的。嗯，你觉得拿破仑怎么样？不，不，不，不，我……他喜欢制服。重申一下，我认为法西斯主义是在非常特定的环境下孕育出来的。因此，我认为把法西斯主义仅仅与征服欧洲、或者拥有法西斯分子等同起来是不够的。显然，希特勒和墨索里尼借鉴了历史上的元素来为他们的外表、品牌和形象增添色彩。但与此同时，他们又是20世纪独一无二的……
they could only have existed in the 20th century because they you know muslimi is all about planes and yeah cars and fascism hitler's brand of fascism would be unthinkable i think without darwinism so let me uh challenge that or at least allow Anders Newgaard to challenge it. He says there seem to be two ways of discussing fascism. One is your way, Tom, and anything my way, which is historically based. And he gives the example of the historian Richard Evans wrote an article in the New Statesman the other week about whether a well-known current political figure was a fascist. And he said, no, because it's all about World War I. And he said, the other way of thinking about fascism is about a culture and a temperament.
他们只能存在于20世纪，因为——你知道，墨索里尼完全关乎飞机和汽车，而希特勒的法西斯主义品牌，如果没有达尔文主义的话，我认为是不可想象的。那么让我来挑战一下这个观点，或者至少让安德斯·纽加德（Anders Nygard）来挑战一下。他说，讨论法西斯主义似乎有两种方式。一种是你的方式，汤姆，还有一种是我这种以历史为基础的方式。他举了历史学家理查德·埃文斯（Richard Evans）上周在《新政治家》杂志上发表的一篇文章为例，文章探讨了一位著名的现任政治人物是否是法西斯分子。他说，不是，因为这一切都与第一次世界大战有关。他说，另一种思考法西斯主义的方式是把它当作一种文化和气质。
So he gives the example, Umberto Eco talked about fascism. So there's a kind of violence and a kind of, and all those things. I mean, you can see that in earlier periods, can't you? You have fascist type, people with a fascist mentality. Well, I mean, I don't think that it's um it's a surprise to say that in the past there have been leaders who have put a value on violence and who have
因此他举了翁贝托·艾柯（Umberto Eco）讨论法西斯主义的例子。所以存在一种暴力和某种……所有这些东西。我的意思是，你在早期历史阶段也能看到这一点，对吧？你会有法西斯类型的人，拥有法西斯心态的人。好吧，我的意思是，我认为过去曾有过一些重视暴力并……的领导人，这并不奇怪。
launched wars of conquest and who have disliked um other groups of people but i think it's the i think i think particularly with uh with german fascism it's the way that this is kind of presented as a pseudoscience so right um the idea so hitler is um you know he he talks about how um apes massacre um elements that are alien to their community and he says well, well, if apes do this, then obviously this is what nature wants humans to do. And it's a crucial part of his perspective, of Himmler's perspective, that human dignity is a Jewish myth. There is no such thing that human beings
发动了征服战争，并且不喜欢其他群体的人，但我认为，特别是在德国法西斯主义中，这种心态被包装成了一种伪科学，这才是……对，嗯，这种观点——希特勒曾谈到……你知道，他谈到灵长类动物如何屠杀他们社群中格格不入的成员，他说，好吧，如果连灵长类动物都这么做，那么这显然就是自然界希望人类去做的事。这是他的视角、希姆莱的视角中至关重要的一部分：人类的尊严是一个犹太神话。根本没有这种东西，人类……
are a part of nature, like every other animal, and that the law of nature is the survival of the fittest, and that if you don't destroy your enemies, then your enemies will destroy you. And it's that distinctively kind of cod-Darwinian perspective that is imposed on it that I think gives to particularly German fascism its distinctive quality. And I think without that, it's not fascism. Okay, but let me ask you a question from Roland Miners. So Roland Miners wants to know about the Romans, and he says, how fascist were the Romans? Now, you've already said, you know, it's a distinctive movement, early 20th century. And yet, at the same time, you say, one of the things that's distinctive about it is its rejection of Christianity. So I'm wondering whether, to pick up Roland's question, you think that in a way fascism is turning the clock back to this
只是自然的一部分，就像其他任何动物一样，自然规律就是适者生存，如果你不消灭你的敌人，你的敌人就会消灭你。正是这种独特的伪达尔文主义视角被强加其中，我认为这赋予了德国法西斯主义其独特的特质。如果没有这一点，我认为它就不是法西斯主义。好吧，但让我问你一个罗兰·迈纳斯（Roland Miners）提出的问题。罗兰·迈纳斯想了解罗马人，他问：罗马人有多大程度的法西斯化？现在，你刚才已经说过，这是一个独特的运动，产生于20世纪初。然而与此同时，你又说，它独特的地方之一在于它对基督教的拒绝。所以我很好奇，借用罗兰的问题，你是否认为从某种程度上讲，法西斯主义是在将时钟拨回到……
pre-Christianity, whether you can see the Romans and the fascists as bookends, and Christianity is in the middle, and there's a continuity there. That is how Mussolini and Hitler want to see it. And again, what Hitler is doing to the Romans is he is racialising them. And he's doing what people always do, which is to take their own perspectives, their own assumptions, and project them back onto the past. So Hitler's interpretation of the Romans is that the ruling classes in ancient Rome, in the Republic, the patricians, the aristocracy, the senate, are of Nordic stock, that they are blonde. And that the plebeian masses, the mob, are not, are inferior, are kind of shot through with Jewish and African racial characteristics. And therefore, Hitler says that they are inferior um and rome is great and is able to
前基督教时期，你是否可以将罗马人和法西斯分子视为两端的书挡，而基督教夹在中间，这里面有一种延续性？墨索里尼和希特勒正是这样看待它的。同样，希特勒对罗马人的处理方式是将他们种族化。他做了人们一直在做的事情，那就是把他们自己的视角、他们自己的假设投射到过去。因此，希特勒对罗马人的解读是，古罗马共和国的统治阶级——贵族、元老院——具有诺斯迪克血统（北欧血统），他们是金发碧眼的。而平民大众、暴民则不是，他们是低等的，夹杂着犹太和非洲种族特征。因此，希特勒说他们是低等的……罗马之所以伟大，并且能够……
conquer the mediterranean while it is led by blonde arians and the effect of conquering the mediterranean is that this nordic stock in in rome as in greece gets diluted by inferior elements and that is what culminates in the collapse of the Roman Empire. And, you know, this is ahistorical and it's ascientific, but it is a kind of way of understanding the world that is unthinkable without the legacy of Darwinian science. And yet, Tom, I mean, this is an immensely frivolous question, which to which I'm, you know, I'm no stranger to frivolous comments. Imagine that you took a Roman from the first century AD or something, and you dropped them in the 1930s. Is it not the case that they would look at Mussolini's Italy, or later on Hitler's Germany, and think of them as more
在金发雅利安人的领导下征服地中海，而征服地中海的结果是，罗马（就像希腊一样）的这种北欧血统被劣质元素稀释了，而这正是罗马帝国崩溃的顶峰。而且，你知道，这是反历史的、反科学的，但它是一种理解世界的方式，如果没有达尔文主义科学的遗产，这是不可想象的。然而，汤姆，我的意思是，这是一个极其轻率的问题，而我对发表轻率的评论并不陌生。想象一下，如果你把一个公元1世纪左右的罗马人抓来，把他们扔进20世纪30年代。难道他们不会把墨索里尼的意大利、或者后来的希特勒的德国，看作是比他们眼中的自由民主的英国和法国那种无政府状态、混乱不堪的社会更……
sane, well-ordered recognizable societies than what they would surely see as the sort of anarchic confusion woolly confusion of liberal democratic britain and france well they would obviously recognize um symbols and architectural styles because both mussolini and hitler are on them. Because of the cult of Rome. So it's easy for Mussolini, because he's Italian, so this is part of the kind of culture. For Hitler, Rome is the great archetype. He goes to Paris and says it's okay, but it's not as good as Rome.
理智、井然有序、且更可识别的社会吗？好吧，他们显然会认出符号和建筑风格，因为墨索里尼和希特勒都在使用它们。因为有罗马崇拜。所以对墨索里尼来说这很容易，因为他是意大利人，所以这是那种文化的一部分。对希特勒来说，罗马是伟大的原型。他去巴黎时说那里还行，但不如罗马好。
That's what he wants to build when the Nazis win the war. He wants to build a city that will very consciously and deliberately put Rome, ancient Rome, in the shade. But I think, yes, I mean, the sense that the Romans are governed by a pre-Christian, as Hitler would frame it, a pre-Jewish sense of morality is obviously very important. And it's not just the Nazis who draw that equation. So Seaman Vale famously did this as well. I mean, she said that 2,000 years ago, it's not the ancient Germans who were like the Nazis, it's the Romans. And so she does kind of recognise that. I think there's an element that the readiness of the Romans to go to war and to celebrate war is something that Hitler and different. And just to kind of, you know, to take a few symbols from
当纳粹赢得战争时，这就是他想要建造的东西。他想建造一座刻意地、深思熟虑地将古罗马比下去的城市。但我想，是的，罗马人受一种前基督教的——按照希特勒的说法——前犹太道德观支配的这种感觉显然非常重要。而且不仅仅是纳粹得出这样的等式。西蒙·薇伊（Simone Weil）也曾著名地这样说过。我的意思是她说，2000年前，像纳粹的不是古代日耳曼人，而是罗马人。所以她确实意识到了这一点。我认为罗马人随时准备开战并颂扬战争的这种倾向，是希特勒和……不同的地方。仅仅从……中挑选几个符号……
ancient Rome here and a few kind of emblems from Sparta there doesn't mean that you are recreating the ancient world. Fascism is a very, very modern ideology. Okay, I buy that. Easy question for you. SMC, was Oliver Cromwell a fascist? No. Yeah. I'd agree with that. I think that's pretty... How about a more difficult one? Well, I think it's time for one for you, isn't it? Okay, we'll ask you. What's a difficult question you've come up,
古罗马的符号和斯巴达的徽章，并不意味着你正在重现古代世界。法西斯主义是一种非常非常现代的意识形态。好吧，我接受这个解释。给你一个简单的问题。SMC问：奥利弗·克伦威尔（Oliver Cromwell）是法西斯分子吗？不是。是的。我同意这一点。我认为这相当……来个更难的怎么样？好吧，我想该轮到我问你一个了，对吧？好吧，我们来问你。你脑子里想出的难题是什么，
but you can put it to yourself. So it's Rebecca Redil, who is historian herself. Yes. And she says, I don't know whether I should take this as a personal insult, does history and do historians enable fascism? So I guess it's, you know, does a sense of history, you know, do historians make fascism possible through their myth-making
但你可以自己回答。这是丽贝卡·雷迪尔（Rebecca Redil）提出的，她本身就是一位历史学家。是的。她说——我不知道我是该把它当作人身攻击还是别的——历史和历史学家是否在助长法西斯主义？所以我想这是在问，历史感，历史学家是否通过他们的神话制造……
and all the rest of it? Yes. Fascism, again, is unthinkable without a sense of history. Yeah. You need the backstory, don't you? Whether it's Mussolini's sense that his Italy is the inheritor of ancient Rome, or Hitler's sense that the history of Nordic supremacy is written in the pages of the history book. I think that an enormous number of historians, particularly in the Third Reich, were suborned by that. And, you know, it wasn't just that they were kind of
以及所有这些东西，使得法西斯主义成为可能？是的。同样，没有历史感，法西斯主义是不可想象的。是的。你需要背景故事，不是吗？无论是墨索里尼认为他的意大利是古罗马的继承者，还是希特勒认为北欧至上主义的历史被写在历史书的字里行间。我认为有数量惊人的历史学家，特别是在第三帝国时期，被这种思想收买并利用了。而且，你知道，这不仅仅是他们……
paying lip service to this theory, this understanding of history as a way of keeping their jobs. I mean, they enthusiastically collaborated with it. I agree completely. And I think actually one of my more sort of heretical ideas that sometimes annoys people is people often say, well, it's very important. We touched on this in the lessons of history.
为了保住饭碗而对这一理论、对这种历史理解敷衍了事。我的意思是，他们极其热烈地与之合作。我完全同意。实际上，我有一个比较异端的想法，有时会惹恼别人：人们经常说，这非常重要——我们刚才在历史的教训中也提到了这一点。我们吸取历史教训、尽可能多地研究历史是极其重要的，因为这意味着我们都会对彼此非常友善。而我认为，往往是那些对历史了解很多的人，把它当作互相残杀的借口。有时，你了解得越多，你对过去的记忆越多，过去就越会变成一座监狱和一种……对暴力的某种辩护。我的意思是，我们可以在世界上每一个地方看到这样的社会：人们对历史记忆犹太深刻，
It's terribly important that we learn the lessons of history and we study history as much as possible because it'll mean we're all very kind to each other. And I think often people who know a lot about history use it as an excuse to kill each other. Sometimes the more you know the more you remember the past the more the past becomes a prison and an and a sort of justification for violence i mean we can see in everywhere in the world societies where people remember history too much and in a
某种程度上，他们被历史所禁锢，历史成为了……为屠杀辩护的工具。绝对是这样，而且我认为这种感觉——你知道，历史是一场我们正挣扎着要醒来的噩梦——与另一种观点相对应，即历史照亮并使我们能够更好地理解现在和未来……我认为我们已经讨论得够多了。好吧，不仅仅是因为我们通过告诉听众如果他们听得太多……我想以一个凯旋的音符结束，因为有一条来自埃斯特·奥赖利博士（Dr. Esther O'Reilly）的推文，她说：我敢打赌你们整期节目都不敢提到特朗普。
sense and they they use it as a you know they're imprisoned by it and history becomes um the sort of justification for for slaughter absolutely and i think the sense that um you know history is a nightmare from which we're struggling to wake up is the counterpart to the idea that history um sheds a light and enables us to understand the present and the future better um i think that that we have uh we've covered enough there well not least because we talked to our listeners away from the podcast by telling them that if they listen too much i i want to end on a triumphant note um because there's there was one tweet from dr esther o'reilly who said i dare you to do the whole episode without mentioning Trump.
啪！我们刚刚提到他了！我还以为我们避开了呢！啪！好吧，这大概是我们自作自受。如果我们到处乱扔像“法西斯主义”这样的词，我们注定会收到大量的信件，也注定会在回答问题时露馅。无论如何，非常感谢你们所有的推文。很抱歉我们没能一一读完。现在，本周四我们有一期非常精彩的播客，内容完全关于英国的南北分歧——喝茶（tea）还是吃正餐（dinner），浴缸（bath）还是洗澡（bath）——我们请到了一位杰出的嘉宾，丹·杰克逊（Dan Jackson），他写了诺森比亚的权威历史，所以千万不要错过，它非常迷人，而且具有法西斯主义永远不会有的趣味。那么，今天就到这里。再见。
Dab! We just mentioned him! I thought we'd done it! Dab! Well, that probably serves us right. If we're going to throw around words like fascism, we're bound to get an enormous postbag and we're bound to get caught out by our answers to the questions. Anyway, thank you so much for all your tweets. I'm sorry we couldn't get through them all. Now, this Thursday, we have a very exciting podcast it's all about the north south divide in britain tea or dinner bath or bath and we have a brilliant guest uh dan jackson um who wrote the definitive history of northumbria so don't miss that it's fascinating and it is fun in a way that fascism will never be. So bye for now. Goodbye.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家加更节目、提前解锁内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社群，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。
Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。欲获取独家加更节目、提前收听权限、无广告体验并加入我们的聊天社区，请前往 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。